Hell is the question.
What would you say is a drug?
Traffic has biggest dream,
blow blow,
Romo,
pop,
pop sites or pornography go.
All right.
Allow me to explain myself because we
all have dreams.
You mean politicians and of course drug
traffickers,
they are no exception.
They are people too.
There may be hard to believe in law,
sort of the ruthless and cruel drug
trafficking in industry because there
are human beings with names.
And in this case also nicknamed zoo.
Just like everyone else have dreams.
So let's get back to my original
question.
What is the biggest dream that a drug
trafficker could have?
I mean,
of course they might be different
possible answers and it cause we're all
individuals.
But unfortunately history tells us that
if most drug traffickers good,
make a wish,
just one single wish,
it would be to turn the country into a
narco state.
That is to say they would turn them into
states,
run by a kind of criminal corporation,
meetup of politicians,
public officials,
judges,
the police and the military,
which in one way or another we're
associated with drugs way drug traffic
is good.
Basically Act with impunity.
Exporting and distributing narcotics is
without any restrictions.
Very recently here on visual politic,
we spoke about how the bolivarian regime
of Nicolas Maduro dl start Okabe Oh and
the cartel de los [inaudible] was
turning Venezuela into a narco state.
However,
in Latin America,
a politics that goes far beyond
Venezuela.
In this video,
we're going to find out it's a bit more
about one character who was able to
promote the alliance between the
narcotics industry and politicians,
so listen up
[inaudible].
Okay.
Narco populism.
We,
no,
it's the narcotics industry is one of
the most important illegal businesses
every year and moved several hundred
billion dollars.
Now allow me to ask another question.
Do you think that are cartel can survive
without political support?
Can they survive without controlling the
institutions in some way?
To answer this question.
Let's go back to the beginning and take
a look at how the most important drug
dealers of all time managed to do it.
It's because even though it's true that
in the beginning,
drug traffickers started out as little
more than a band of outlaws.
The time came when this all changed.
A time came and so did it.
Protagonists,
Blue Escobar Gaviria considered by
Forbes magazine to be one of the richest
men of his time on the entire planet.
According to Forbes in 1987 Pablo
Escobar had a fortune that exceeded $2
billion and Escobar,
he radically changed the global drug
industry.
Great.
See on the one hand,
so you created an entire network of
criminal holding company that included
businesses like kidnapping,
murder,
and of course their main activity of
drug trafficking.
All of these activities were perfectly
integrated into a structure.
The metagene cartel,
which has a clear organizational chart,
a well defined hierarchy,
and even a zone based distribution
network,
each with its own managers talking in
business speak these words sort of like
franchises or branches.
On the other hand is regarding his main
business drugs.
This cartel,
the Mexican cartel,
achieved an almost complete vertical
integration.
That is the cartel took over the
harvest,
the production,
the distribution,
and the marketing of the vast majority
of its merchandise.
They did everything and they took over
every single stage of the business.
That's how the Medellin cartel and
managed to bring in more than $7 billion
per year.
Of course,
none of this would've been possible
without the complicity of the public
authority.
Yeah.
Lee Escobar reached the top of the
cocaine cartel by astutely reinvesting
his initial earnings and becoming a PR
master in Colombia.
With his growing wealth.
Escobar bought a newspaper in Midian,
gained influence in Colombian politics
and he successfully ran for public
office becoming an alternative to the
national congress.
David Henry Forbes magazine,
you see,
for many years,
Pablo Escobar had impunity with his
money and threads.
The well known phrase of Silver
[inaudible].
He managed to infiltrate the Colombian
state.
He bribes the military,
politicians,
governors,
and the police in such a way that many
Colombian institutions were under his
command for a long time and that's not
all.
Pablo Escobar also financed electoral
campaigns to win popular support.
And what does a politician do when he
wants to gain popularity fast?
Well,
he promoted projects like the building
of houses for the nation's poorest
citizens as well as distributing
provisions and creating soccer field.
It's pretty good,
doesn't it?
I mean at first glance,
kind of like a Colombian Robin Hood,
too bad.
The truth was rather defer while he was
carrying out this type of campaign.
He had no qualms about flooding the
streets with violence and blood.
Welcome to knock a popular,
as you will probably know,
Pablo Escobar managed to hold a seat in
the Colombian parliaments in 1982 until
then,
thanks to his political influence and
his pr strategies,
he was able to build his embar and is
huge fortune with the
osmosis impunity.
A member of the United States Drug
Enforcement Agency once said that
importing exotic animals for his zoo
caused escobar more problems with the
government.
That is drug business.
David Henry
now,
oh,
hold on just a second.
Don't think the Pablo Escobar's
political relations,
what limited to Colombia at all after
being elected as a deputy,
the,
it became untenable,
but some members of the media began
telling the truth behind his fortune.
The DEA is pressure multiplied.
A lot of Colombian society understood
the huge danger that's Pablo Escobar
posed and other cartels,
they began to fear the power that the
median cartel would grow into.
That's when the government began to
persecute this capo,
which in a way declared war on the
Colombian state itself and just to be
safe.
The first thing Escobar did was leave
the country less.
Td hunted down
the lead,
sorry,
Pablo Escobar put some space between
himself and Columbia.
The question is,
where could he find refuge?
Would his drug money be enough to
strengthen his alliances?
Well,
it seems absolutely so.
First of all,
there was panel at that time,
the military dictator manual,
Antonio Noreaga offered asylum
protection and to root to transport his
merchandise.
So imagine this industry was so powerful
that even dictators were willing to sell
their services.
The fact is that as you can see in her
ego,
also turns Panama into a narco state.
That is until 1989 when a lightening
invasion by the United States removed
him from power.
He was detained,
taken to the United States,
and given 30 years in prison for his
drug trafficking and his relationship
with a median cartel.
This,
this is not the end of Palu Escobar's
external alliances.
The truth is that he didn't feel very
safe and Panama either.
I mean,
yes,
the dictator of the country was his pal,
but the CIA had a very large presence in
the country.
So when he needs to expected it to,
Nuria could be attempted to sell him out
because of course it was one thing to do
business with a Panamanian dictator.
It's quite another to and trust him with
his protection.
He needed to find a new destination.
So through the left wing,
Colombian guerrilla movements am 19
Pablo Escobar contacted the Nicaraguan
government.
Don't remember
the Sandinista government board led by
the country's current president.
Daniel Ortega was willing to welcome
them with open arms in exchange for a
commission,
you know,
for services rendered.
The agreement specified that in addition
to settling in the country with his
family,
if Pablo could use some of Nicaragua,
was regions as a drug distribution
platform,
the problem or take her in his friends,
they were very greedy.
So a few months later,
Pavlo decided to return to Columbia,
but of course he maintained his business
relations.
This mole along with Nicaragua,
the m 19 gorillas also facilitated the
median cartels contacts with the Cuban
governor.
Yup,
that's
right.
Cuba was also a trading platform for
Pablo Escobar's businesses.
In fact,
it is known that Pablo Escobar
maintained good relations with the
Castro brothers,
although truthfully,
it seems that he wasn't the only one.
All evidence indicates that after
Escobar rather drug dealers continue to
use during the Castro is to introduce
all types of narcotics into the United
States anyway,
Colombia,
Panama,
and Nicaragua.
Cuba.
As you can see,
a political power was one of the main
drivers of the huge presence of drug
trafficking and Latin America.
The lack of transparency,
the corruption,
lack of counterweights and weak
institutions where a perfect breeding
grounds for what over the years became
one of the great and nightmares of this
region.
And yes,
some of you might now be thinking,
well,
all right Simon,
but in the end,
Pablo Escobar,
he fell from power.
Yeah,
it's true,
but when a man like Escobar falls,
it doesn't mean that the industry falls
and can order their relations with
political power.
Let's have a look at Mexico.
The relay,
the main Mexican cartel with which Pablo
Escobar had a relationship was the
Guadalajara cartel led by Anesto Fon,
second,
Rafael Caro,
Quintero and Niguel and hell Felix
Guyardo.
This cartel had full impunity for two
decades.
All thanks to their relations with
people in power.
See Felix,
Guy Otto was in charge of public
relations and thanks to his ability to
move within the highest political
spheres.
This cartel had all the stability it
needed to develop and grow.
Pr Is really important.
We're talking about a criminal industry
and in criminal organizations,
stability is very hard to achieve.
In this case,
the assaults on the dea agents on reggae
arena,
which ends it,
his life made Washington demands the
dismantling of this cartel and it's neat
as fell one by one,
but this didn't end the business from
prison in 1989 Phoenix Guyardo tried to
reorganize the territories,
but in the absence of an agreement with
the cartel,
it's listened to the tijuana cartel led
by the Ra on her brothers and the
Sinaloa cartel led by Hector Louis
Palmar Salazar,
[inaudible] Palmer and Hakim Guzman
Maria.
Okay,
I'll chapo.
They both debuted on the Forbes list in
2009 with an estimated 14 of more than
$1 billion.
Okay.
The fact is that under El Chapo has come
on,
the scene or lower cartel became the
most important and influential cartel in
Mexico and one of the most important
criminal organizations in the world.
The question that many of you might be
asking now is how did he do it?
How can one cartel grow so much more
than its adversaries?
What above all,
it's because of political influences.
For example,
how do you prevent the federal police
from cashing you and nine your business?
Well,
you would do that by finding out a,
when those raids are going to happen,
everything is based on good relations
and that's precisely what El Chapo made
sure that he would have inflammation and
friends,
uh,
power as we've seen in other cases.
I'll chappy's capture it.
Didn't really change the panorama today.
This isn't a lower cartel is controlled
by Ismael l mayors and Bardo,
who over the years has been known to buy
officials from the special prosecutor's
office,
the Attorney General's office,
and even the Counter Narcotics
Intelligence Center and elite army corps
creators to fight narcotics.
Obviously they don't do these businesses
alone.
In many cases,
they have the approval or participation
of the authorities Fj our researcher at
the University of Guadalajara,
this is all done in complicity with
senior government official
only that explains these criminal
groups,
power,
strength and resilience.
We're talking about it,
but let's go power with which in many
cases norcos create a symbiosis that is
hard to distinguish.
That's what's happening in Venezuela
with a soulless cartel of which we've
already spoken here on visual politic
and watch out because it's estimated
that the Mexican and Venezuelan cartels
control 70% of all drugs and tend to the
United States.
That's what happens in countries like
Guatemala where some sources,
states and the time to 80% of all the
white powder could be mediated by
members of the national army itself.
Oh,
what's happening in Honduras where even
the son of former presidents Porfirio
Lobo has been condemned in the United
States for drug trafficking activities
while his own father was president of
the republic.
Anyway,
folks,
that is the result of having weak
institutions,
a lack of transparency and the lack of
counterweights in future videos.
We're going to talk more about this
issue,
which is becoming very expensive class
in American countries.
With this video,
we just wanted to show you a few
examples of how some of the greater
norcos succeeded largely thanks to their
influence on established institutions.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos.
Also,
don't forget to check it off.
Friends and the reconsider media
podcasts,
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine.
Also,
this channel is possible because of
Patriarchy and our patrons on that
platform.
Please do consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage.
And as always,
I'll see you in the next [inaudible].
Okay.